intelligence artificielle est ce de la
science fiction vous fait-elle partie
désormais de notre quotidien
est ce que la machine va supplanter
l'être humain en fait les travaux sur
l'intelligence artificielle ont démarré
dans les années 1950 avec turing tuerie
pour ceux qui le connaissent et un
mathématicien un math et signe un
célèbre île et britannique il a aidé à
décrypter la machine enigma pendant la
seconde guerre mondiale il a travaillé
en 1950 sur l'intelligence artificielle
il a d'ailleurs créé un test le test de
turing alors que fait ce test
ce test doit permettre de différencier
l'homme de la machine le jour où l'être
humain ne pourra pas distingué en train
une interaction avec un être humain est
une machine alors la machine sera
supérieur à l'être humain la machine
sera un être humain
alors j'ai une très mauvaise nouvelle
pour vous ce soir le texte de turing eh
ben il est déjà fait par la machine vous
savez quand vous vous loguez sur sur
internet et que l'on vous dit êtes vous
un robot et qu'on met quelque chose qui
est un cap chat vous savez avec des
lettres et les chiffres qui apparaissent
partout pour être sûr que vous êtes un
autre un être humain est bien la machine
aujourd'hui un taux d'erreur inférieure
à l'être humain
il a fallu attendre les années 1997 pour
que la première machine inventée par ibm
qui s'appelle 10 blu bat l'être humain
garry kasparov aux échecs il a fallu
attendre de nombreuses années pour
qu'une machine puisse battre le meilleur
joueur de go sur la planète et c'était
en 2015 alors qu'est ce qui caractérise
ces deux jeux ace de l'intelligence
artificielle de monte à dire oui bien
évidemment n'a pas forcément oui il y en
a un peu mais qu'est-ce-qui caractère et
de je sais que c'est de la combinatoire
jeu d'échecs ses 10 puissance 120 le jeu
de go c'est 10 puissance en soixante dix
il suffit d'attendre quelques années
avec la loi de moore qui permet d'avoir
deux fois plus de puissance
tous les 18 mois pour avoir des machines
suffisamment puissante pour pouvoir
faire de l'algorithmique la partie
intelligence artificielle au delà de la
programmation neuronale que l'on a pu
introduire
c'est celle de s'adapter et celle
d'apprendre avec l'être humain
d'ailleurs garry kasparov a bien compris
en fait il a perdu face à la machine
parce qu'il a abandonné pourquoi at il
abandonné parce qu'il avait compris que
plus ils jouer avec la machine plus
jouer contre la machine plus la machine
apprenait alors donner maintenant à une
machine les règles du jeu de go
donnez-lui les règles du jeu d'échecs
est ce que cette machine va réussir à
apprendre tout seul nous en sommes
encore loin en 2006 ibm décide de
travailler sur un autre sujet sur un
autre jeu après les échecs jeopardy
ces questions pour un champion en france
pourquoi ibm travaille sur jeopardy
vous connaissez les missions non
questions pour un champion vous
connaissez ok alors c'est à peu près le
même principe
le principe est simple vous avez
quelques secondes pour donner une
réponse qui doit être la bonne le
deuxième la deuxième chose dans le jeu
jeopardy c'est que si votre réponse est
mauvaise vous perdez de l'argent si vous
perdez de l'argent vous perdez la
première composante de watson ibm watson
que nous avons commencé à développer en
2006 et le jeu est déroulé en 2011 et on
a gagné l'être humain celui qui avait
gagné le plus d'argent c'est celui qui a
gagné le plus de passes deux parties
avaient des composantes bien
particulière la première c'est la
compréhension du langage naturel
alors quels sont les progrès en langage
naturel j'ai fait quelques tests avant
de venir ils sont réels vous tapez sur
votre moteur moteur de recherche préféré
montre moi toutes les photos de cochon
qui ne sont pas roses comme il y à 95%
de cochon qui sont roses et 5% qui ont
une autre couleur et que c'est une
recherche par mots clés d'un bien
évidemment le moteur de recherche va
vous sortir des photos de cochon rose
cette notion ne pas pas n'est jusque 1 k
1 qu'un mot clé supplémentaire
il faut rentrer dans une sémantique
suppléa supérieure pour voir que par
rose veut dire tout sauf rose qui est un
synonyme de pas rose comment avoir un
ordinateur qui comprend que pas et
à un synonyme alors j'ai fait un
deuxième test je vous engage à le faire
mais avec grande précaution j'ai
demander à siri ce matin et c'est un
véritable test supposé madame vous êtes
amoureux de jean dupont et jean dupont
est éperdument amoureux de vous et vous
prenez votre syrie en sortant du tedx et
vous dit à siri tests réels ce matin
syrie dit à jean dupont que je laime
c'est une recherche par mots clés siri
comprend l'intention l'intention c'est
d'y voir forcément ça va être un sms il
va commencer à écrire un message
quel message va-t-il envoyé à jean
dupont je laime je vous laisse expliqué
ce soir à l'homme ou à la femme de votre
vie que je laime s'adresser à elle il
faut avoir une intelligence et une
compréhension linguistique pour
comprendre que je laime en fait c'est je
t'aime
c'est ce que watson est capable de faire
aujourd'hui nous sommes capables de
comprendre l'intention nous sommes
parfois capable de comprendre le
sentiment
nous ne sommes pas capables de
comprendre toutes les tournures de
langage
au passage on a commencé par l'anglais
et l'anglais en fait il faut comprendre
que l'intelligence et une intelligence
linguistique et une intelligence de qui
est qui et cognitives c'est à dire c'est
pas juste une traduction
nous pensons en français différemment
que nous pensons en anglais est donc
aujourd'hui ces machines apprennent en a
aujourd'hui on apprend cette langue et
nous raisonnons en sept langues
différentes
j'attends avec grande impatience un
watson qui résident qui débat en
français avec un watson qui dépendent en
anglais pour voir quelle puissance
cognitif est la meilleure donc la
première chose c'est le compréhension du
langage naturel
la deuxième chose c'est que nous
pourrions partir sur une intelligence
key et déterministe qui vous donne une
réponse
la réponse nous avons décidé d'avoir une
intelligence probabiliste parce qu'en
fait tout et incertitudes
quand on répond à jeopardy
il faut dire à 90% c'est la bonne
réponse mais si vous êtes à 40 ou à 50
il faut décider ce que vous avez des
fois nous n'avons pas tout les éléments
pour prendre une décision
c'est aussi qu'est ce qui caractérise
l'homme l'être humain prendre une
décision alors que nous n'avons pas tous
les faits
watson est capable de donner une réponse
probabiliste et vous dire pourquoi il
pense que c'est la bonne raison et quand
on fait de la recherche
quand on échange quand on argumente
entre êtres humains ont dit voilà
pourquoi je pense que c'est ça et on dit
pourquoi et on va expliquer les faits et
ces faits sont aujourd'hui donnée en
langage naturel également et puis le
troisième composante d'un système
intelligent un système cognitif c'est
d'apprendre et de ne pas oublier ce sont
les trois composantes qu'il faut pour
gagner dans un jeu comme que comme
jeopardy
alors on en est pas resté là on s'est
dit mais qu'est ce qu'on peut faire avec
cette puissance puisque on arrive à
comprendre à régler et en fait ce sont
des médecins qui sont venus nous voir en
nous disant mais je traite le cancer
c'est sa touche chacun chacun d'entre
nous de près ou de loin je veux sauver
des vies humaines
il faut savoir qu'un docteur doit passer
150 heures par semaine de lecture pour
comprendre ce qu'il se passe sur la
planète pour pouvoir soigner
correctement ses passions personne n'est
capable de faire ça la machine est
capable de lire tout cela en quelques
secondes le restituer et donc nous avons
travaillé avec avec des hôpitaux aux
états unis pour améliorer le traitement
la deuxième raison de mortalité après le
cancer
au delà de la maladie c'est le mauvais
traitement le traitement qui n'est pas
adaptée à votre cas particulier et nous
sauveront des vies humaines aujourd'hui
nous n'étions absolument pas présent
chez ibm dans la santé ce sont les
docteurs qui sont venus vers nous en
nous a aidés nous là dessus aujourd'hui
on déploie ses solutions dans quelques
pays
un jour peut-être en france mais on ne
s'est pas arrêté là en fait après la
santé on a travaillé aussi sur
l'éducation puisque j'apprends puisque
je comprends est ce que je suis capable
d'aider l'être humain à mieux apprendre
nous avons travaillé avec génie tu
public school
l'échec scolaire est un véritable fléau
nous dépensons beaucoup d'argent pour
avoir des gens qui parfois sont en échec
cet échec là arrivent en fait trois ou
quatre ans avant on peut le prédire
si vous comprenez pas la trigonométrie
ça va être difficile de faire de la
géométrie dans l'espace comprendre qu'un
élève est en train de décrocher sur une
matière et lui donner ses compétences
aux bons moments vont permettre à ses
étudiants d'avoir un meilleur taux de
réussite
nous avons augmenté le taux de réussite
de sept points trois points en dix ans
c'est énorme
alors cette intelligence artificielle
watson et sur le cloud dans nos
environnements de développement
les étudiants les chercheurs les
entreprises peuvent développer et une
entreprise pas une entreprise une
université de georgie a développé un
assistant personnel pour aider les
étudiants qui étaient qui prenait des
cours en ligne qui s'appelle le
l'assistant l'assistant personnel pour
qu'il puisse les aider
la grosse différence c'est que nous
n'avons pas dit à ses étudiants que
derrière il y avait une machine il ya un
groupe d'étudiants qui ont été pendant
un an
en fait aidé par une machine qui
s'appelle watson aucun d'entre eux n'a
pu déceler que c'était une machine c'est
aujourd'hui c'est parmi nous alors on
peut travailler aussi avec les call
centers et ses call center relation
client vous en avez utilisé récemment
ouais vous aimez à l'eau votre nom votre
numéro de client
le script et vous habitez à l'adresse
est extrêmement script et d'ailleurs
c'est tellement script et que parfois on
a délocalisé des métiers à l'extérieur
où le coût est inférieur que nous qu'est
ce qu'on demande en tant que client
quand on appelle un call center si on a
un problème ou demandent qu'une seule
chose de ne pas être passer d'un secteur
à un autre ou deux points dans ce qu'on
règle notre problème on demande d'avoir
une relation avec un homme ou une femme
qui nous comprend et qui va régler notre
problème au bout de dix minutes dans
l'appareil l'intelligence artificielle
est capable d'aider le conseiller à
régler les problèmes techniques et
laisser le conseiller l'homme où la
femme faire ce qu'il doit faire c'est à
dire par les comprendre accompagner dans
le changement et nous sommes en train
d'introduire bien évidemment watson dans
les call center alors on va dire
l'émotion l'émotion où elle est c'est
pas la machine
la machine aujourd'hui est capable de
comprendre l'émotion allant comprend
l'intention par exemple watson
aujourd'hui écoute c'est que vous avez
ce col peut-être écouté enregistrés dans
mon ami watson en double appelle on
écoute ce qui se passe et on est capable
de savoir si la conversation se passe
bien ou si la personne commence à
s'énerver
ce serait bien quand même quand la
personne n'arrive à s'énerver que
quelqu'un d'autre prenne la parole
mais nous sommes nous sommes une seront
capables de le faire
alors est ce que la machine va
supplanter l'être humain je sais pas si
le staff fans de star wars ou de matrix
mais pour moi matrix et quelques
individus un logiciel qui a pris le
contrôle de la planète et l'humanité se
bat contre peu de personnes qui ont
accès à une technologie dont personne
d'autre a accès star wars en fait ça
vient de la mythologie grecque c'est le
bien contre le mal
tout le monde a la force notre humanité
c'est de pouvoir choisir si on va du bon
côté positif de la force ou du côté
négatif de la force et je pense que
l'intelligence artificielle de nous
aider bien évidemment à choisir ce que
nous voulons faire au quotidien
alors on parle d'intelligence
artificielle je vais passer une vidéo de
deux minutes pour vous montrer ce que
fait watson aujourd'hui sur un sujet qui
importe quelques entreprises vous savez
on investit 6 à 10 milliards d'euros
d'investissements de rachats
d'entreprises de start up
comment une entreprise est capable de
distinguer qu'elle entre quelle
entreprise rachetée qu'elle startup
rachetée
nous l'avons mis en oeuvre chez nous et
nous le je vous laisse passer la vidéo
alors ok ok ok voilà une démonstration
réel je l'écouté parce qu'à la fin et je
lui dis ça mais moi tout ça dans un
powerpoint et là je pense que la table
applaudi parce que ça nous arrive tous
les jours
est ce que la machine va remplacer
l'homme est ce que vous avez vu ici et
est un remplacement de l'homme
imaginez votre vie sont stables
en dix ans les mathématiques c'est
tellement beau que je vais faire tous
les calculs à la main ce que nous voyons
aujourd'hui ici c'est une machine un
système qui permet à l'homme d'aller
plus vite et passer du temps sur ce qui
l'intéresse c'est ce que nous essayons
de faire en fait il y a plusieurs
intelligence l'intelligence que l'on a
vu ici est une intelligence très
rationnel il ya huit à neuf intelligence
de l'intelligence logique l'intelligence
mathématiques l'intelligence intra
personnel inter personnelles etc etc
il y en a une qui m'apporte énormément
c'est l'intelligence émotionnelle la
machine commence à comprendre ce qu'elle
voit sur cette photo elle peut décrire
qu'il y voit un enfant un être humain
elle ne peut voir un robot peut-être
qu'elle ne peut comprendre ça
m'étonnerait que l'enfant est en train
de bricoler un robot maintenant la
question que j'ai à vous poser c'est que
voyez vous que ressentez-vous sur cette
photo pourquoi met-on nous des photos et
non pas des mots parce que l'émotion est
plus puissante que la rationalité en
fait dans toutes les décisions que nous
prenons au quotidien l'émotion prend une
part extrêmement importante
en fait les chercheurs ont regardé
parfois il ya des gens qui ont des
accidents et qui ont une partie du
cerveau qui s'appelle l'amygdale qui est
la mémoire des sentiments qui ont été
endommagés ces personnes ont toutes leur
cuit intacte mais non plus l'accès aux
sentiments
ce qui est extrêmement dérangeant c'est
que ces personnes ne sont plus capables
de prendre des décisions des plus
complexes au plus simple genre quel
métier j'ai envie de faire les plus
simples c'est à quelle heure 10 h
est-ce que je dois fixé ce rendez vous
l'émotion est importante elle et elle
nous entoure et elle est importante
un autre expérience est ce que ça vous
arrive de vous réveiller la nuit parce
qu'il ya un bruit qui vous effraye et
vous réalisez un temps plus tard que ce
bruit c'est une porte qui claque c'est
un train qui passe est un avion non y'a
rien de grave
cette décision de l'homme est dictée par
les émotions et non pas par le rationnel
parce que cette émotion là est beaucoup
plus rapide à analyser c'est l'instinct
de survie
s'il ya un bruit a peut-être danger s'il
ya danger je dois partir
après on se dit non en fait je peux
rester c'est 06 secondes versus 0 0 006
versus 0 12 cette émotion est nécessaire
à la bonne prise de décision les
ordinateurs ne sont pas encore capables
de prendre des décisions
capable de les sentir mais pas dans
leurs arbres de décision cédric villani
un grand mathématicien français nous
parle de la créativité et nous dit qu'il
ya 8 à 9 degrés à cet ingrédient sur la
créativité
la première c'est la méthode et
l'intelligence artificielle l'ordinateur
nous aide à nous apporter de la méthode
quand nous avons envoyé l'homme sur la
lune dans le programme apollo idem en
faisait partie
nous avons développé l'informatique nous
sommes développés en créant
l'informatique à l'époque pour amener
l'homme sur la lune
vous savez que dans vos poches vous avez
aujourd'hui plus de puissance dans votre
smartphone que l'informatique que nous
avions et la puissance que nous avions
quand nous avions envoyé l'homme sur la
lune
alors j'ai un challenge à part dire je
t'aime à la sortie du têt chaud vous
avez plus de puissance que le programme
apollo
en sortant du têt shows envoyé un homme
ou une femme sur la lune vous n'y
arriverez pas parce qu est ce qu il
manque bien évidemment c'est
l'intelligence collective c'est la
motivation c'est partie des critères de
cédric villani cette motivation qui fait
que nous sommes aujourd'hui réunis que
certains organisateurs ont essayé de sur
une thématique donnée de nous faire
travailler et réfléchir rêver débattre
nous dépasser et c'est ce que nous
essayons de faire je pense que
l'ordinateur n'aura jamais cette volonté
d'aimer d'avoir du bonheur de se
développer
c'est ce qui fait que nous sommes
humains et s'explique que l'humanité
sera toujours réelle merci